he has won and won big in everything
he's driven hey guys I'm William Byron I
Drive the 24 car in the NASCAR Cup
Series I started racing when I was 15
years old and then before that I raced
on I racing which is like a computer
game basically learned how to drive on
there and then got started racing real
cars and have driven ever since
basically just get up eight o'clock 8:30
I go train it's funny my trainer you
know he's just joking he's like oh yeah
you know you just drive in circles for a
living and I'm like it's definitely
interesting because that is what we're
doing you know actually but there's a
lot of training that goes into it the
training we do is just is all physical
stuff of trying to get your heart rate
really high and be able to recover cars
get to be a hundred forty degrees during
the race and your body really wears down
and over time from that and also you're
holding on and you're tensing up and
you're also getting pushed by the
g-forces in the car to the to the rider
or left people ask a lot about like
crashes or what's the biggest hit you've
had honestly I had a pretty big hit last
year I hit the wall pretty hard got a
little airborne yeah I've never really
been injured I've just had you know
soreness and things like that our race
cars are pretty safe the only difference
though is like you you don't necessarily
get hurt but when you hit a wall it
feels like a baseball bat hits you in
the stomach if you think about getting
hurt I think it's it slows you down so I
think you block it out completely and
just try to focus on on the race I think
I'm the baby of the of the series we get
a lot of age comments like oh you look
so young and you know I do but it's like
it's different to be so young but I
don't really worry about it like when I
put the helmet on it's kind of it's kind
of game morning
I mean I do school work still so I'm
still a college student so that probably
would surprise some people you know you
have to introduce yourself to the class
so I kind of feel weird talking about
you know I raced these cars so it's a
little different yeah I was scared of
failing my driving test in never
parallel parked I used two feet when I
Drive and most people you know use one
foot I think it's weird that people use
one foot so I was worried about those
two things I thought I was gonna fail
but it was okay thankfully no no I been
close I had a one I got pulled over one
time going like 55 and then 30 or
something it was a warning so it's all
good my family when we come home for the
holidays and we're all together they
hate the fact that I sit in the back
right seat and I critique everything
going on especially after the fact like
oh well you should have done this I'm a
very like task-oriented so it's like
everything has to be done like now and
and if it's like if something's like put
off by it I struggle with that so it's
like I gotta do things and then like get
done with them yeah they come to some
races I mean I try to get my friends to
come out to Charlotte and some of the
local places that I race so it's always
cool to see them they they wear the
t-shirts and look like a fan it's pretty
cool yeah it is hard I mean most of most
of my friends are gone you know during
the week when I'm home so most of my
friends outside of racing are kind of
you know I see them once or twice every
few months but the people I know in
racing we kind of become friends because
we're always seeing each other well I
think racing is um it's kind of like
golf you don't know how difficult it is
till you kind of get out there and do it
so I feel like if we could get people in
the car more and get them to kind of
drive and or sit next to somebody and
drive if we could do that to the casual
fan it would be awesome because I think
you know it would help them understand
what's going on
if I have to go to the restroom where
you know how I do that during the race
you know honestly like you get the
adrenaline going and you don't really
need to use the restroom when you're in
the car
but if you do like this Nomex is is okay
so but try not to
[Music]
[Music]